CBS News has learned Hollywood mogul
Harvey Weinstein made a last-ditch
effort to save his career he sent a
letter asking several movie industry
executives for support just hours before
he was fired from his company Weinstein
wrote quote I am desperate for your help
the letter was first reported by The
Hollywood Reporter's Janice min and then
confirmed by CBS News a number of
celebrities are speaking out including
Kate Winslet Meryl Streep and Judi Dench
Jericka Duncan sat down with a
journalist who shared her encounter with
Weinstein Jericka good morning good
morning ten years ago Lawrence Vaughn
was a local reporter in Long Island New
York Sivan met Harvey Weinstein and
mixed company at a dinner party but when
he offered her a private tour of his
restaurant she says she was stunned by
the encounter the details of their first
and only meeting are graphic when he
asked me if I wanted to tour the
restaurant or the kitchen no there was
no apprehension should there have been
yes it was 2007 and journalist Lawrence
Vaughn said she got a very friendly vibe
from Harvey Weinstein I didn't get
anything that read he was dangerous
until we got downstairs and what
happened he tried to kiss me and I I
pushed him off politely and that's when
he seemed to get angry or annoyed and
told me to just stand there and be quiet
so Vaughn said Weinstein had her
cornered he exposed himself and he
basically pleasured himself and when he
finished I said to him are we done here
can I leave because he had been blocking
the exit several actors who were hired
by Weinstein have spoken out against him
including Meryl Streep who said the
behavior is inexcusable but Weinstein
was defended by fashion icon Donna Karan
it's not Harvey Weinstein you look at
everything all over the world today you
know and how women are dressing and
you know what they're asking by just
presenting themselves the way they do
what are they asking for trouble
Karen apologized yesterday saying my
statements were taken out of context and
do not represent how I feel I am truly
sorry to anyone that I offended Sivan
told us some have been critical of her
for not speaking out sooner I don't like
that idea of blaming the victim like
blame him you know blame the people that
enabled him George Clooney told the
Daily Beast's Weinstein's behavior is
indefensible he said this is the moment
to start scaring people like this into
not acting this way any more CBS News
has repeatedly reached out to Harvey
Weinstein and the weinstein company for
comment but we have not heard back Nora
all right Jericka thank you so much